I was looking at my Miami Marlins here
their record last year was 57 in 105 but
our good buddy Don Mattingly Donny
baseball just got a contract extension
there at the Marlins a couple months
back they finished 40 games back a first
place Don Mattingly the Marlins manager
joins us on the program how do you not
take all those losses home with you I
mean you have to take it home to some
degree because you have to I think you
have to take it personal right you take
it personal make sure that you're doing
everything you can to help these guys
grow again keep the perspective you know
I know where the organization is going
and I know what our plan is and but just
to keep that perspective make sure I'm
continuing to teach continue and stay
our be keeping my staff upbeat and what
we're trying to do and again just keep
taking that silver lining of things and
keep trying to grow this thing how often
are you getting Astros questions not too
much obviously we weren't a team or an
organization that's been involved with
that not sure we had too many players
that were you know part of that so we
haven't gotten a whole lot just the
general you know your feelings and your
opinions on it all right well then since
you're not getting those questions let
me give you a couple how did you how did
you feel about what bringing that up
yeah I mean the overall what they were
doing like how much should this bother
us I think it should bother us to a
point where we make sure we make their
adjustments because they honestly you
could see it coming and not just with
him just with technology how good the
cameras were getting an instant replay
came in there was so many more views
because of the instant replay that you
had access to
you could kind of see it coming and but
you you wouldn't have you know I don't
think anybody thought to this degree
right and I think that's what bothers us
they got it was you know you know to
this degree you know bothers you as an
industry you know once your games
looking like that
you don't want the perception of your
game in that in that light and so I
think the fact that you know the
commissioners report he came down on the
organization everybody has a has an
opinion past that but it kind of just
adds to the fire from you know I've
never seen players on players like this
yeah yeah you know kind of that attack
and you know I guess you notice you
never tell a guy what to say or what not
say but at some point you hope that hey
we we we agree that it's wrong there was
a problem you hope their guys understand
that but we have to move on as a sport
because we have to make changes in the
game has to grow when I say the name
Mike fires what do you think of you know
just I think as a player in the
clubhouse you just liked it to have you
know taking that stance
you know while he's there and I think
that's the biggest thing obviously
coming to light and you can't really you
know Odyssey has to protect another team
Inc now but I think as a player that
little thing of you know after the fact
makes it different then hey you could
have handled it you could have spoke up
right then right there within a
clubhouse situation and maybe you put
into it what do you think when I say AJ
Hinch tough spot for ad I know you know
I know AJ is a good person
you know I think you get caught
sometimes as a manager protecting your
guys and you know at some point I think
you know I I feel I actually feel bad
for him from the standpoint of you know
what he's going through obviously
changes a life family life you know you
don't know where it goes from here
afterwards but I think it's a learning
situation for all of us that you know it
as leaders of your club you've got to
stand up for what you believe is right
and sounds like he didn't feel good
about
but he didn't take that next step yeah
that's what I was wondering if players
are doing it they're successful and if
you might have one of your veteran
players saying guys everybody's doing
this like I I don't know if AJ Hinch
could has I guess he could have stopped
it but I just wonder about what exactly
everybody's role was in something like
this and and how prevalent is this you
know the Red Sox are gonna get spanked
here by the commissioner soon I don't
know if there are other teams that I
mean I would be shocked if they're the
only teams that did this done well the
one thing we were going all the way back
to 17 and 17 there I don't believe
anything had came out as we got a memo
and I believe that started in 18 about
the use of technology so there was
nothing that really said you can't do it
and I couldn't look at it along the
lines of the steroid era dan you know
you knew the scare was they weren't
illegal right there was no testing so
you can't say hey these things are
illegal within the sport but you know
they're wrong I mean so it's that's the
point where you know where you take it
so that's after 17 anything after 17 if
it continued to me it really gets
because of the league it came out and
set direct things that you the way you
can and cannot use technology yeah and
there's nothing on the books right now
and there's no deterrent really from the
standpoint of just hey you're gonna be
embarrassed maybe they're not taking
away a trophy or anything and if anybody
gets punished it's going to be your
manager or general manager here
I would go back on that a little bit
there's a lot more in place like I said
after 17 the minerals came out the
directives came out you know they've
made strides within within the video
rooms where they had a guide over the
last two seeds and you couldn't have a
camera a direct feed on the you know
home plate they could go down into your
dugout so there
were things that they were doing but see
we're going back to 17 before they had
any of those in place and and so I think
teams were probably using technologies
to get signs before games just not to
the to the degree where you're getting
them in real time what did you start
getting it real time and that's when you
start getting those you know the you
know the banging and stuff like that
that's a whole different thing being
kind of studying the catcher's you know
ahead of the series knowing what guys
signs they use and it's our fault for
not having complicated enough signs or
switching them you know within a game
and so it's a little the real-time thing
is the real problem talking to Don
Mattingly the Marlins manager I had your
batting I think 352 and 1986 right I
think so right around there okay yeah if
you knew this signs bad year what do you
think you would have hit I don't know I
look at it differently if I could have
ran you know it's always been going on a
guy get the second base or guy see stuff
with the guy's glove or tipping or doing
something I was never a guy that liked
it very much because I was never
confident that that guy got it out there
so I wasn't a guy to used it like that
but I look at it like if I could only
bring that year Dan do you know how many
career stolen bases you have I probably
could count them on on a boat no no that
no you can count it on your body you
stole 14 bases in 14 years oh wow hey I
got two in one game too though I got one
twice at one game you should have been
pacing yourself you had to be exhausted
after that game I feel bad for that
catcher who was the catcher you stole
two bags on or maybe it was a double
steal you were the back end
the double steel house Jeter since that
one guy didn't vote for him for the Hall
of Fame as he has he been moping around
that's still amazing though I just want
to know and look everybody can vote now
however you want to vote I just love to
know rationale that one person who said
this is why I didn't vote for Derek
Jeter what could that rationale possibly
be I'm with you on that right I mean
career hits championships played every
day played a long time yeah that's
that's for me how can you look at that
vote though you know I just don't see
this guy the whole thing and the thing
is is when it gets to the Hall of Fame I
just believe you just say is that guy
Hall of Famer yes or no and with Jeter I
don't think anybody anybody who is
conscious conscious could say yeah yeah
if he's a Hall of Famer or not yeah I'm
with you on that too the thing I'd be
again how can you look at just as
numbers and everything you accomplished
and then say no to that and vote no it's
great to talk to you and keep your
spirits up there and congrats on getting
your contract extended there all right
hey we're looking keep an eye on us
we're going to be a lot more competitive
so it's gonna be a it's going to be a
better year like I told our media the
media that show up is that you know
we're going to be disappointed this year
if we're not considerably better so I
think we're going to be a lot tougher
team to put away this year if you make
the playoffs then I'm bringing the show
down there to the ballpark yeah for the
whole last month before in the hunt
you should be there the whole oh no no
no we can't do that I mean you gotta
make the playoffs downing come on just
working I'm sorry I'm going for the top
right and then we end up at 15 days and
we're good and what's the over/under of
ejections for you this year
I gotta stay low I got a new [ __ ] coach
and James I don't want to put into the
gun James rel oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
stay calm this year dan like I always
say but I did tell James I said you got
to make sure you're up to speed
will you get thrown out of a game before
June 1st I'm gonna say no on that I'm
gonna say yes I'm gonna yep I think in
May you're gonna get steamed okay we'll
see I'm feeling good I'm feeling
confident doing a lot of yoga yoga I
want to see you in yoga poses in the
dugout though calming your mind here
during a game you know what's going on
good to talk to you thank you done John
Mattingly for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]